came up with this idea come on let's do
it all again well I think I think we
sort of had talked about it for a while
and we knew that we wanted to make
um you know a special celebration of the
20 years and we came up with the idea of
going and re-recording our old songs and
and putting that out as an album with
some feature artists so we're doing that
we've just been out of La doing that
um and yeah the tour is going to be in
September and I think for busted fans
this is the tour to come to because it's
going to be a full celebration of like
you know everything that the fans loved
about busted in the first place so um
we're super excited about